-Who doesn't love
Reese Witherspoon?
-Oh.
-Welcome back...
-Thank you.
...to "The Tonight Show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks so much for coming on.
I'm so happy to see you
in person in the holidays.
-Last time I saw you was on
Zoom, and it was just so...
-It's so tough.
-It's nice to be here.
-Thank you. I appreciate it.
We all appreciate it.
I see all of y'all.
Thank you very much. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Happy holidays to you
and the fam.
What goes on
in Reese Witherspoon
in the holidays?
-Oh, gosh.
Well, lots of singing
of Christmas carols.
-Yes.
-I like --
-Are you --
What?
-Are you a caroler?
Do you go out and like?
-Oh, I mean,
I don't think so anymore
-Just in house.
-When I was a kid,
we used to go door-to-door.
-You did?
-Yeah.
-Oh, wow.
-I grew up going door-to-door,
but now I just
stay home and watch
Michael Bublé specials.
[ Laughs ]-
That's what everyone does now.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
-I love the Bubs.
-Are you? I love the Bubs,
-Wait, that sound like...
-Yeah, I know. It's weird.
It sounded weirder when I said
it. I don't know why.
[ Laughter ]
We love the Bublé.
We love him.
-We love Michael Bublé.
[ Laughter ]
What just --
what just happened?
-Why does this happen?
Sorry, it doesn't matter.
-I have a friend who calls
him Michael Bubs.
-The Bubs.
-Because they know him,
but nobody calls him that.
-No, I think you mean
like Justin Bieber --
-That was so weird.
You call Biebs the Bubs.
-The Biebs.
Justin Bieber
you call the Biebs,
Michael Bublé the Bubs.
No, you don't.
[ Laughter ]
-I love the Bubs.
Yeah, I mean...
-Maybe it's Bub-- Bublay.
Oh, my God.
-Yeah, I love the Bublay.
[ Laughter ]
-Quest, help.
-No, no, no, no, no.
Help, I'm drowning.
Is it hot in here?
-No, please, please, please.
Look, I want to talk to you
about because, you know,
I follow on on the socials...
-Oh, my God.
-...and I -- you're very --
you're very crafty.
You love to cook.
-I love a crafternoon, y'all.
-Oh, craft...
-When you craft
in the afternoons,
it's crafternoon.
[ Laughter ]
You're making up all sorts
of new words.
Crafternoon.
You have to trademark that.
-Oh, my gosh.
-But -- but you...
Look at this. This is you making
a gingerbread house.
-Oh, yeah.
-This crushes what
I was making for my kid.
Oh, my gosh.
-It's a very special pattern,
and...
-That's so much fun.
-Most of the materials
were eaten by the end.
That's what my kids do.
They do it,
and then they just wait
and they're,
"Can I just take that off?"
I go, "Just destroy it
and eat it."
-Just eat it, just eat it.
-Just go for it.
-I mean, did you -- was your mom
into a gingerbread house
when you were growing up
and, like, did that for you?
-Yeah. Well, we grew up
partially in Germany
because my dad
was in the military,
so we always had
gingerbread houses
and like German candies
and stuff like that.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-I had a family.
Katrina Wamsley, the Wamsleys,
and they would --
we would go over to their house
and her mom made all these
different pieces of the house
and had frosting for people.
And were like, "Oh, my gosh."
And that was like --
like a tradition.
-Like a perfect mom.
-It was the best.
I loved it. I go, "Oh, my gosh."
It was so cool.
-Ms. Wamsley?
-Yeah, Ms. Wamsley, yeah.
-Making everybody's
childhood magical.
-Yeah, she just --
Yeah, she did, yeah.
I will say season
two of "Morning Show..."
-Aww, did you like it?
-I loved it.
-Oh, thank you.
-Not only liked it, loved it.
-Thank you. It was fun.
-You took it to the next level,
and we talked about on Zoom,
but it is very topical.
It is controversial,
but you nailed every single
little detail, and I'm like,
oh, my gosh.
it was as another great one.
And I just binged out too,
because I just went crazy.
And then big twist.
-Big twist?
-Oh, yeah.
-You know what I'm taking about.
-No, I don't.
[ Laughter ]
Oh.
Oh, yeah. Okay.
Oh, right. Yes.
-Big twist.
Big twist for me, man.
Oh, my gosh.
Anyway.
-Did you recover, though?
You're okay?
-I loved it.
I loved every second of it.
I did not see that thing coming.
-Yeah, you're right,
you're right,
-But there's so --
there's so many
other things I go, that's such
a well-written
way of doing that.
-It is such a well-written show.
-Because what if that
actually was a situation
that happened?
How would people react?
What would happen?
It was just great.
-Right.
Well, y'all probably have
some of those experiences
because you have to put
on a show every single day
or two shows
or three shows, so.
-Yeah, it's wild.
-Yeah.
-It's a lot of different
people, you know,
with different motivations,
and...
-Yeah.
You had such a busy year,
but I will say -- I want to show
the cover of --
the cover of Time.
You're on the cover
of Time Magazine.
Not too shabby right there.
"Hello Sunshine."
And then this is
my favorite one.
And you can not even
react to this picture
because I think it's so cool.
You're on Forbes, the world's
most powerful women 2021.
Here is a picture of you.
[ Laughter ]
And then look up here.
Look up here.
That's the queen
right there, yeah.
-Oh, yeah,
Yeah, yeah, you and the queen.
-I call her QE.
-You call QE?
Yeah, do you --
but you call her...
No, you're probably
just close friends.
I call her Queenie.
Queenie, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Congrats.
-I never met the Queen.
-I want to talk
about scene two,
and then show a clip of that
When we come back.
More with Reese Witherspoon.
Everybody stick around.
Come on back.